[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
DANA VETTER: So you'll
go on the far side.
Hello, everyone.
Can you hear me?
Hi.
BRAD PAISLEY: Hi.
DANA VETTER: What a
warm introduction.
My name is Dana Vetter.
I work on music programs
on YouTube.
And I am thrilled to be joined
by Brad Paisley.
BRAD PAISLEY: Hi.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
DANA VETTER: Not much
introduction needed--
I think we have a lot of fans
in the audience-- but
acclaimed singer, songwriter,
guitarist, musician,
critically acclaimed,
awards, et cetera.
So thank you so much for
joining us at Google.
BRAD PAISLEY: Is that
where we're at?
DANA VETTER: We are at
the Googleplex here.
So let's just get started.
So I know you just got
off the plane.
Let's just dive right in.
You're about halfway
through your tour.
BRAD PAISLEY: Yeah.
DANA VETTER: About--
BRAD PAISLEY: It seems
like it, yeah.
DANA VETTER: I think, yep.
And so you're here
in California.
We're thrilled to have you here
performing locally tonight.
But I want to actually
talk about somebody
else's tour for a second.
A couple weeks ago, you joined
The Rolling Stones on stage--
BRAD PAISLEY: Yeah.
DANA VETTER: --in
Philadelphia.
BRAD PAISLEY: They
need more press.
Let's do that.
DANA VETTER: Well, I just want
to know, how did that happen?
Like, did they call you?
Like, what is that
moment like?
BRAD PAISLEY: They're
desperate.
DANA VETTER: They're desperate,
[LAUGHING].
BRAD PAISLEY: They're
trying really hard
to matter in music.
And that's been what their
whole tour is about.
They have had a lot of people
do that in various cities.
They're the consummate
sort of jam band.
I mean, they really are all
about getting up there and
playing music and bringing it.
DANA VETTER: Um, hm.
BRAD PAISLEY: And then, on top
of that, what's it sound like
to collaborate?
What's it like to bring in
other formats of music?
And throughout the tour, it
sort of ran the gamut of
people that sat in.
And we had a few
country people.
We had a lot of rock and
rollers, a lot of
blues guys, you know.
And you're seeing their
influences,
which is kind of cool.
And then--
I'm not one other influences--
but I am influenced by some of
the same people they
are, you know.
They actually have a very
heavy country base--
DANA VETTER: Um, hm.
BRAD PAISLEY: --you know.
They were a great country band
when they wanted to be, on
certain songs.
And there's this common
language with us.
I've gotten to know Ronnie
Wood pretty well.
I'm starting to get to
Mick pretty well.
And it's like you realize that
guitar is sort of the
universal--
DANA VETTER: Um, hm.
BRAD PAISLEY: --language
of music.
Especially the guitar players
have this really sort of
foreign thing.
My wife, as an actress,
is envious.
Because she's seen me jump in
with everybody from The
Rolling Stones to BB King, to
you know, like Keb' Mo' is a
friend of ours.
And I'll just get up
in the middle of a
blues night with him.
DANA VETTER: Um, hm.
BRAD PAISLEY: She's like, it's
like you speak French.
DANA VETTER: Right, right,
right, right.
BRAD PAISLEY: It's like
this foreign language.
And you guys start, and then
we get backstage, and it's
like, what pedal is that
that you're using?
Well, that's brand new.
It's this new analog delay,
and it's wonderful.
And the next thing you know,
you're off in this--
DANA VETTER: Right,
another language.
BRAD PAISLEY: Yeah, this French
competition that she
doesn't understand.
DANA VETTER: Well, it's
interesting, because you're
one of these amazing country
artists who's a great
singer/songwriter.
But like you said, you're
a killer guitar lead.
BRAD PAISLEY: I didn't
say that.
DANA VETTER: Well, I'm
going to say that.
I'm going to say that.
BRAD PAISLEY: But
like you said--
DANA VETTER: Well,
right, right.
So this--
BRAD PAISLEY: This is like,
between two ferns up here.
DANA VETTER: It is.
Between two screens here, so--
nap pods--
that's like, we have nap pods at
Google, which is a place--
BRAD PAISLEY: Nap pods?
DANA VETTER: Nap pods.
BRAD PAISLEY: We have
those on a bus.
Those are called bunks.
[LAUGHTER]
DANA VETTER: Right.
And so we were actually joking
about between two ferns and
saying we should start one
that's between two nap pods.
It's where you go and
kind of take a rest.
BRAD PAISLEY: All right.
Bring 'em on.
DANA VETTER: Anyway, we
can give you a tour of
the nap pods next.
And I know that some of the
Grammys that you've won are
for some of the instrumental
stuff.
So how do you balance, kind of,
that, you know, the guitar
interest and then also, you
know, your talents in singing
and songwriting?
BRAD PAISLEY: My sound man
always accuses me of singing
to get to the next solo.
Because truthfully, when you've
sung a song a million
times, like whether that be
"Celebrity" or "Alcohol" or
one of these songs that go back
a few years, you know,
there are only so many ways
you can sing the verse--
DANA VETTER: Um, hm.
BRAD PAISLEY: --before people
leave and think
you've lost your mind.
He's changing the
melody too much.
But, and here comes the solos.
DANA VETTER: Uh, huh.
BRAD PAISLEY: And for me, it's
like, I could add a little.
I could go into a pentatonic
thing here and really make
that kind of cool.
O
DANA VETTER: So that's
how you keep it--
BRAD PAISLEY: That's
really the gist.
Yeah, and at our heart, my band
and I are a bit of a jam
band, in spite of the technology
that we use and the
video we've got to sync up with
and the way that you've
got to keep the hits
also recognizable.
DANA VETTER: Sure.
BRAD PAISLEY: There's always
those moments in the show when
you can have free expression.
And I think that's what
will keep me going.
You know, remaining nameless,
there was a country artist
who's a big hero of
mine that I had a
conversation with once.
And it was early in my career.
And I said, are you playing
many shows this year?
And he said, yeah, I'm
doing, you know, I
don't know, 40 or 50.
And he said, what about you?
I said, I'm doing 200.
Of course, when you're
new, you do.
You'll play 200 dates a year
just because you need to.
DANA VETTER: You need to.
BRAD PAISLEY: And people
need to see you play.
DANA VETTER: Right.
BRAD PAISLEY: And he said, oh,
golly, how do you do that?
And I said, well, you
know, I love it.
And he said, give it time.
[LAUGHTER]
BRAD PAISLEY: And he's right
about one thing.
There's parts of it
that get old.
But one thing that never gets
old to me is that I'm there
for sound check.
I mean, I can't wait to play--
DANA VETTER: Right.
BRAD PAISLEY: --and jam and
see how my amps sound that
day, because every day is
different, and make my guitar
tech go nuts, because I've
got a new pedal I
want to try on a song.
And here he is, you know, and
something will go wrong.
And a cable will get,
you know, because
I messed with it.
But that's the fun of it.
DANA VETTER: That's great.
So let's talk a little
bit about the tour.
At Google, we have this
thing called the Dory.
And that's where we get
Crowd-sourced questions.
So some of the questions I'm
going to ask you are from the
audience, essentially.
And everyone will vote on if
they like the question or
dislike the question.
BRAD PAISLEY: And what
about the answer?
Do they vote on that?
Because that's really going
to be disappointing.
DANA VETTER: So one question
they had is what's it like to
play in California versus other
places that you have
been touring?
BRAD PAISLEY: I would say-- and
I run the risk of making
other people mad--
but I would say this is
our favorite state--
DANA VETTER: Really?
BRAD PAISLEY: --four touring.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
DANA VETTER: You don't
say that everywhere?
BRAD PAISLEY: I don't
say that everywhere.
DANA VETTER: OK.
You heard it here first.
BRAD PAISLEY: I can't say that
about another state.
I mean, it's fun
to play Texas.
It's fun to play Georgia.
But there's always cities in
those, and I won't name 'em,
but there's always a city in
each of those states that I'm
talking about that you
dread a little bit.
Because it's like they're a
little jaded or they're--
DANA VETTER: OK.
BRAD PAISLEY: But it is not the
case in California for us.
DANA VETTER: Cool, OK.
BRAD PAISLEY: There is not
a bad place we play--
DANA VETTER: Great.
BRAD PAISLEY: --knock on wood.
DANA VETTER: That's great.
I love that.
And so, towards the end of the
tour you're heading to
international destinations.
And another question from the
Dory is, not many country
artists can fill as many seats
as you can internationally.
And so--
BRAD PAISLEY: Feel
as many seats?
DANA VETTER: Fill, fill--
BRAD PAISLEY: Fill
as many seats.
DANA VETTER: Butts in seats,
butts in seats.
BRAD PAISLEY: Gotcha, got it.
All right.
DANA VETTER: Or feel.
BRAD PAISLEY: Feel
as many seats.
Yes.
DANA VETTER: So what do you
attribute some of that to?
Could you speculate?
BRAD PAISLEY: I think
it's always songs.
I think that the minute you
start to think it's you and
not the songs you're singing
is the minute
you're about to--
DANA VETTER: It's almost over.
BRAD PAISLEY: --you're about to
pee in a bucket backstage
in a kitchen or something.
You know, you're about to
get arrested speeding--
DANA VETTER: Ooh, a poker
reference there.
BRAD PAISLEY: Yeah, going
through your subdivision, and
then flip off the cop, and,
you know, I don't know.
Because you're starting
to think it's you.
You're starting to think you're
larger than life.
And truthfully, it's
always about songs.
Because I have always been of
the belief that any artist
that sang the 22 hits,
you know, 22 chart
toppers I've had--
DANA VETTER: Um, hm.
BRAD PAISLEY: --would be a
star, probably as big, or
maybe bigger than me, you
know, in that sense.
Because I'm lucky that I found
some that were wonderful.
I'm lucky to have written a
few that really worked.
And it really comes
down to that.
People, when they say, that's my
story that you're singing.
Or we used this at
our wedding.
Or, you know, we played this
at a funeral, or we--
that's how you get people
to go see you play.
DANA VETTER: That's how you
get them in those seats.
BRAD PAISLEY: Songs.
DANA VETTER: Songs.
So speaking of songs that mean
something to people, I grew up
in Kentucky.
I love "Southern Comfort Zone,"
which is one of the
hits off of your latest
album, "Wheel House."
And I don't know if you guys
have seen this video, but in
the video, you--
BRAD PAISLEY: The director
is sitting right there.
DANA VETTER: Oh,
OK, a director.
Where is he?
BRAD PAISLEY: That's our
director Jim Shea.
He directed me.
DANA VETTER: So in this video,
you mic up a tractor.
BRAD PAISLEY: Yeah.
DANA VETTER: You've
got cameos from an
elephant and some giraffes.
BRAD PAISLEY: Right.
DANA VETTER: And you hit eight
countries in eight days, is
that right?
BRAD PAISLEY: We did.
DANA VETTER: So where did
this idea come from?
Tell me about this video.
BRAD PAISLEY: That's one of the
most unique, fun things
we've ever attempted.
And what that was, the song is
about, for those of you who
are watching that may not
know, the song "Southern
Comfort Zone" sounds like we're
saying about drinking--
DANA VETTER: Right, SoCo.
BRAD PAISLEY: --alcohol in,
like, the back of the truck.
But we purposefully, on this
album, set out to write songs
that sort of zigged when you
thought they would zag.
DANA VETTER: Um, hm.
BRAD PAISLEY: You know, they
were supposed to be
unpredictable and new
angles on topics.
And so the angle that we took
with it was you are literally
really the most thankful for
this place you're from when
you see the world.
And you appreciate new
things about it.
Like you come back from
a place like--
one of my charities I'm involved
with is Haiti-- you
come back from a place like
Haiti, and you're just excited
about the fact that
your faucets work.
DANA VETTER: Right.
BRAD PAISLEY: You come back from
Paris, and you think to
yourself, where's that
bakery that's really
good, that's similar?
It's not quite as good, but
it's similar to that--
DANA VETTER: --an inspiration,
right.
Yeah.
BRAD PAISLEY: --that
place. yeah.
Or Italy.
And you're like, I heard a new
artisan coffee shop opened up.
I'd like to see if they're doing
a cappuccino anywhere
near right, you know.
And you come back enlightened
and with a new appreciation of
where you're from.
So how do you illustrate
that in a video?
Ironically, around the time we
were going to do the video, it
was time for me to
go to Europe.
And we had a bunch of
tour dates in London
and Sweden and Norway.
And I'm trying to think
of where else.
DANA VETTER: France, I think,
was in the video.
BRAD PAISLEY: Well, France
is in the video.
We ended up just going there.
We didn't play there.
DANA VETTER: Oh!
BRAD PAISLEY: That was an
excuse to spend a day--
DANA VETTER: --to run through
the streets of Paris.
BRAD PAISLEY: --running through
And so all I knew, when we
started the video, was I
called Jim.
And I said, here's this idea.
The idea is that it starts
with a tractor.
The tractor is the groove
of the song.
It established the click
track with that.
I start the thing.
We mic it with an acoustic.
I hand the acoustic off.
I walk out of frame.
I'm throwing on a jacket.
And I walk into frame
in, say, Stockholm--
DANA VETTER: Um, hm.
BRAD PAISLEY: --which is the
first up of the tour.
So that was all I
knew about that.
And then, we were going
to wind up back at the
tractor at the end.
DANA VETTER: Fun.
BRAD PAISLEY: So whatever
happens in the middle happens.
And so I edited that using an
editing program on my laptop.
DANA VETTER: Really?
BRAD PAISLEY: --as we would
shoot it, yeah.
Edited that myself.
DANA VETTER: You did?
BRAD PAISLEY: Yep.
DANA VETTER: Wow!
BRAD PAISLEY: We would
shoot during the day.
We would go--
I'm a big tech nerd, so--
DANA VETTER: Love this!
BRAD PAISLEY: --very, very
excited about being here.
[LAUGHTER]
BRAD PAISLEY: We would
shoot during the day.
And we started in Stockholm.
And we got to Stockholm,
and it's freezing.
And I know the jacket.
And I had a whole case full
of jackets to choose from.
DANA VETTER: OK.
BRAD PAISLEY: And I knew that
was going to be the--
DANA VETTER: --that you
were doing your own
wardrobe, as well?
BRAD PAISLEY: Yeah, basically.
DANA VETTER: This was like.
BRAD PAISLEY: Yeah,
that's all.
We had no crew whatsoever.
DANA VETTER: The Brad
Paisley DIY video.
I love it.
It's amazing!
BRAD PAISLEY: It really was.
And all I knew is we were going
to get to Stockholm.
And I was going to throw on the
same jacket I was walking
out of frame in and make it
match to where it looks like
one arm is in the jacket and the
next arm comes in as you
walk across a bridge over
whatever the river is.
And then came this idea of,
well, I should run.
If I'm going through Europe, I
mean, there's no way I'm going
to make it through all of
these countries walking.
DANA VETTER: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
BRAD PAISLEY: So I take off
running through the streets.
And then, I had Kendal, my
keyboard player in the band.
I was like, OK, run bus.
And we would get a taxi.
And Jim would sit in, like, the
trunk of the taxi with his
camera as the taxi would
drive about 10 miles an
hour down the road.
And I'm just running
behind it.
DANA VETTER: Yeah, I was
wondering how all
those shots, really--
BRAD PAISLEY: And I would take
off the jacket, and I'd, like,
run beside the taxi.
And I'd throw the jacket
to Kendal.
And he would throw
me another one.
And I would be putting it on
as I'm trying to sing.
DANA VETTER: It really
looks like--
BRAD PAISLEY: Yeah.
DANA VETTER: --the
video's real.
BRAD PAISLEY: Yeah,
and we would edit.
And we would get to, like,
Dublin was the last city.
And we get to Dublin at
the end of this week.
And we had one day.
And I'm editing.
And luckily, I was editing
as we went.
DANA VETTER: And you have
so much time when you're
on tour, I'm sure.
BRAD PAISLEY: We have
at least flights.
And you definitely have downtime
in the daytime.
DANA VETTER: OK, OK.
BRAD PAISLEY: You have
at least all that.
And I'm sitting there editing.
And I went, I never threw
the blue jacket off.
So here I am.
So we just treat it
looks like Italy.
So here we go.
We went out and found, like, a
cobblestone street in Dublin,
tried to make it look like
the sun was out.
DANA VETTER: Oh, my gosh.
BRAD PAISLEY: And threw
the jacket off there.
DANA VETTER: Oh, my gosh.
You had to do a little
reshoot.
BRAD PAISLEY: Yeah,
so it was a little
pickup shot, you know.
DANA VETTER: I love that.
That's great.
So, yeah, if you haven't
watched the
video, check it out.
It's not your average
country music video.
I've got to give you that.
BRAD PAISLEY: No.
DANA VETTER: And a really
creative edit.
I love the backstory.
BRAD PAISLEY: There's a ham
of a giraffe in it.
There's a giraffe that
is actually--
DANA VETTER: A what?
BRAD PAISLEY: A ham
of a giraffe.
DANA VETTER: A hand?
BRAD PAISLEY: It's a ham.
I mean, this giraffe wants
to be on camera.
DANA VETTER: Oh, a
ham of a giraffe.
BRAD PAISLEY: If you
have a camera--
[LAUGHTER]
BRAD PAISLEY: I don't mean
an inedible giraffe.
It's more of a giraffe that
really wants to be a star.
It's the giraffe at
the Nashville Zoo.
His name is Congo.
And it's the biggest dog.
It's like a Great Dane.
But, you know--
DANA VETTER: But a giraffe.
BRAD PAISLEY: --two
stories high.
DANA VETTER: Yeah.
BRAD PAISLEY: And if you
have a camera, that
giraffe goes to it.
DANA VETTER: That's great.
BRAD PAISLEY: It's
really bizarre.
It was just really--
DANA VETTER: I'll have
to go re-watch--
BRAD PAISLEY: Yeah,
he's in it.
DANA VETTER: --and keep an
eye out for the giraffe.
So that's a great story.
So another single--
I think your latest single, "I
Can't Change the World."
BRAD PAISLEY: Yeah.
DANA VETTER: So talk to
me a little about the
origins of that song.
It soft of starts out with
larger issues and then comes
kind of to a personal level.
BRAD PAISLEY: Well, when we
launched this single--
it came out yesterday--
so it's brand spanking --
DANA VETTER: Latest.
BRAD PAISLEY: --new.
Latest, yes.
Latest as in, don't play
it in concert yet.
They don't know it but
hopefully will.
It sort of feels like, with
every single, you have a theme
that you follow, that you chase
as an artist, that will
take you four or five months at
least, to go up the chart,
have people sort of start to
recognize it and really sort
of digest it.
DANA VETTER: Um, hm.
BRAD PAISLEY: And this is
an important one to me.
The hook of the song, for those
of you who haven't heard
it, is I can't change the world,
but I can change yours.
And you're singing it to
a girl in the song.
It's a romantic notion.
But the opening line of the song
is a bomb goes off in a
far off city.
And you deal with the fact that
this world, basically,
thanks to the 24-hour news cycle
and the connectedness of
technology, feels a lot crazier
than it ever did.
DANA VETTER: Um, hm.
BRAD PAISLEY: Whether that's
or not, I don't know.
I mean, you know, I imagine
there were train wrecks in
Europe when I was a kid.
But I never heard about it.
If I did, it was a blurb
in the paper--
DANA VETTER: Right.
BRAD PAISLEY: --days later.
BRAD PAISLEY: But we grieve in
real time, with things that
happen in Indonesia, things
that happen in Europe and
Afghanistan or you name it.
And it's all very overwhelming
for a human being.
I don't know if we're
equipped to sort of
internalize all of that.
DANA VETTER: All of it, yeah.
BRAD PAISLEY: You know,
all of us have our own
situations in our lives.
And the singer of the song
reaches the conclusion that
his cause is this girl and that
he is going to make the
world a better place for her.
DANA VETTER: Um, hm.
BRAD PAISLEY: And in some ways,
it's a larger theme for
life, in the sense that we're
all sort of searching, I
think, for whatever it is that
gives our lives meaning.
And I think that, truthfully,
if you want your life to
matter, then maybe save
someone else--
DANA VETTER: Um, hm.
BRAD PAISLEY: You know?
DANA VETTER: Right.
BRAD PAISLEY: Make else's life
better, and yours mattered.
DANA VETTER: Um, hm.
BRAD PAISLEY: You know,
and In that sense it's
a very large theme.
But it's meant to be romantic.
DANA VETTER: OK, great.
So you started out.
You grew up in West
Virginia, right?
BRAD PAISLEY: Yes, right
next to Kentucky.
DANA VETTER: Right
Yep, my family's from Elkins.
BRAD PAISLEY: Oh,
congratulations.
[LAUGHTER]
DANA VETTER: Anyway, in West
Virginia, you started out
playing at "Jamboree
USA," right--
BRAD PAISLEY: Yeah.
DANA VETTER: --which was an
old weekly radio program.
BRAD PAISLEY: Yes.
DANA VETTER: So back then,
I think you played on the
program for many years.
BRAD PAISLEY: Yeah.
I started when I was
13 on there.
DANA VETTER: OK.
And so back then, you know,
radio was a primary force.
And it certainly continues to be
now, but as one of a number
of things in kind of the
music landscape.
You have elaborate tours.
You have YouTube.
BRAD PAISLEY: Yeah.
DANA VETTER: You have all
the social media.
I mean, it's interesting that
we're sitting here at Google
today, where so much is digital
in technology and
video, and it's a far cry from
when life was radio and three
stations on the TV.
So how do you balance all
of these outlets?
And what's your approach, kind
of, to bringing your music and
kind of also you through
social media
and things like YouTube?
BRAD PAISLEY: It's
interesting.
You know, it's a constant
challenge to try and get
people's attention.
I mean, you can put all of this
time into editing a video
where you run through Paris and
have all of these sort of
segues through Europe and trying
to sort of bridge the
southern mentality with the
sort of world view.
And then, you're upstaged
by, you know,
David at the dentist--
[LAUGHTER]
BRAD PAISLEY: --by a
little kid that's--
DANA VETTER: Right.
BRAD PAISLEY: --on codeine.
[LAUGHTER]
DANA VETTER: You're like,
oh, we almost had it.
BRAD PAISLEY: Right, right.
Yeah, you know.
Get it, or whatever.
And so it's an interesting
time that way.
But also you have so many
opportunities to get your
music out there.
I think it's always about
connecting the dots.
And I'm a very complicated
person.
I'm very hard to figure
out in some ways.
I mean, I have songs
that run the gamut.
DANA VETTER: Right.
BRAD PAISLEY: And some of them
have made people mad.
And some of them have been
completely misunderstood.
And some have been, you know,
totally embraced.
And my fans have a really good
idea of who I am, I think, at
this point.
And the goal is to try and get
those people to misunderstand
me to find something there.
And, you know, Twitter
is a great tool.
You have YouTube, which
is such a great tool.
Because you can be in the middle
of a tour and film, you
know, my drummer, I don't know,
throwing up behind his
drum kit when he gets
food poisoning.
And the next thing you know,
that's bigger than the video
we just made--
DANA VETTER: Right.
BRAD PAISLEY: --or something.
And it's a great way to connect
the dots and let
people feel a part of it.
Because they just want to feel
a part of something, I think,
in this world.
I don't really know if we
do it exactly right.
But if you have any ideas, this
is the room to ask on how
I can make it better.
DANA VETTER: Well, I think you
have a lot of content, I
think, on all of your
social platforms.
And it seems that your videos
are creative, and you're
finding a lot of ways to
engage with people.
So I think it's great.
One thing, actually, I want to
ask, and then we'll take a
question from the audience.
So on YouTube, you know about
this thing on Google and
YouTube-- we have Autofill,
right-- which populates some
frequent searches.
And this is one that I found.
And the Autofill is Brad
Paisley pranks.
And it has--
BRAD PAISLEY: Oh, there's
a bunch of that, yeah.
DANA VETTER: --Brad Paisley
pranks Blake Shelton, pranks
Carrie Underwood, pranks
The Band Perry.
It goes on and on,
this long list--
I don't know if you
guys can see it--
all the way to Brad Paisley
pranks wife.
I mean, a lot of your
songs are funny.
BRAD PAISLEY:
Pranks wife by proposing.
[LAUGHTER]
DANA VETTER: A lot of your
songs are funny.
And you clearly have a pulse
on humor and pop culture.
But what's the story
with these pranks?
Did you grow up as
a prankster?
Are you always watching
your back on the road?
Like, what's the deal?
BRAD PAISLEY: I am
watching my back.
Chris Young, as you know, is our
opening act here tonight.
And he is just out
of the hospital.
He had a staph infection.
And it was a scary thing.
But I talked to him this week,
and he's doing better.
And I had heard rumors that he
might have to do his show
sitting down this evening,
which I was,
like, this is awesome.
Get water guns.
[LAUGHTER]
DANA VETTER: What a welcoming.
BRAD PAISLEY: You know, I'm on
one of these people, that, I
like you if I'm picking
on you.
DANA VETTER: OK.
BRAD PAISLEY: --and was
always that way.
And I've always been a bit
of a prankster, I think.
And I don't always come
off like that.
But man, I could have worked for
the CIA, I'm telling you.
DANA VETTER: You're a sleuth?
BRAD PAISLEY: --because my mind
just thinks that way,
like, oh, you know what
we could do to mess
them up, you know.
And we've done everything from,
like with Kellie Pickler
opening for us, we created
a fake intro video.
She had a video that was the
typical, Kellie Pickler is--
you know-- was on "American
Idol." And that
was her intro video.
And we changed it with a video
called "You Be the Judge."
I took photos off WireImage
and doctored her to where,
like, the early photos of her on
"American Idol," we made it
look like a 12-year-old boy
on the upper torso.
And then the post photos, we
made her look like Dolly
Parton and interviewed a plastic
surgeon and had his
opinion, Dr. Emerson Biggins.
[LAUGHTER]
BRAD PAISLEY: And he gave his
opinion on whether or not she
had sought--
DANA VETTER: Enhancement.
BRAD PAISLEY: --enhancement.
And then, it just left the
audience with questions.
So please welcome
Kellie Pickler.
You be the judge.
DANA VETTER: You be the judge.
BRAD PAISLEY: And that
was her intro video.
And she had to walk out wearing
the tightest tank top
you've ever seen.
[LAUGHTER]
BRAD PAISLEY: And she's, like,
cussing me out backstage.
DANA VETTER: Of course,
of course.
BRAD PAISLEY: But we're
good friends.
And she took it really well.
DANA VETTER: It's so funny.
BRAD PAISLEY: But that's the
kind of stuff we do.
And it goes back to
when I was five.
I pulled the ultimate
prank on my mother.
My dad's here.
I pulled a prank on mother when
I was five years old.
She told me I had to be-- and
this is so wrong, but
it's so who I am--
I had to be in bed by 10 o'clock
on New Year's Eve.
I was five years old.
I knew that all the action
happens at midnight on New
Year's Eve.
DANA VETTER: Right.
OK.
BRAD PAISLEY: But she told my
grandpa, who is my best
friend-- and he's watching me--
and her father, Put him
in bed at 10:00.
We're leaving and going to see
his uncle in the morning at,
like, 8:00 AM.
I don't want him tired.
And I'm mad, because I wanted
to stay up and see the ball
drop, you know, in New York.
And they leave.
And my wheels are spinning.
How can I stay up
til midnight?
DANA VETTER: How
can I stay up?
BRAD PAISLEY: And finally
he asks me one time--
he goes back around.
My dad used to have this
bar in the house--
and he sees the bar.
And I think he might
be having a beer.
And he asks me, he says, Brad--
and we used to have
deep discussions-- does your
mom ever drink alcohol?
And I said, all the time.
[LAUGHTER]
BRAD PAISLEY: And he said,
what do you mean?
I said, all.
Sometimes, Dad has
to carry her in.
[LAUGHTER]
BRAD PAISLEY: I don't know
how I knew that.
And he's like, really?
And I went into detail about the
nights when she's slurring
her speech and everything.
DANA VETTER: No, this is a
YouTube video for that.
BRAD PAISLEY: Yeah, I should
recreate it with
little child actors.
And anyway, they get
home at 1:00.
And I'm standing there and arms
crossed in the kitchen,
wide awake.
He's kept me up for evidence.
And she walks through the
door and says, what
are you doing up?
And he says, never mind him!
DANA VETTER: What
are you doing?
BRAD PAISLEY: I didn't raise
you like this, Woman.
[LAUGHTER]
BRAD PAISLEY: And then, she's
like, well, what are you
talking about?
And he's going off.
My mother never drinks.
But she used to love Kahlua
in her coffee.
And so I go find a bottle
of Kahlua in the bar
and show it to him.
And he doesn't know Kahlua is.
He's an old, like,
Kentucky redneck.
He's looking at it.
Its 80 proof.
That's all he needs.
This is hers.
And then, he goes off.
And my dad's saying, you're
out of line, Warren.
And I remember this.
And he goes over to her.
He says, you did this to her!
[LAUGHTER]
BRAD PAISLEY: He storms
off down the alley.
She goes upstairs crying--
and my dad, or,
no, he's still there.
My dad says to me--
or she's saying, Brad, tell
him you're lying!
And I look at him and go,
I wish I could, Mom.
[LAUGHTER]
BRAD PAISLEY: And then
she goes upstairs.
He goes down to his house.
And I had to call him
and apologize and
tell him I was lying.
And I got in trouble.
[LAUGHTER]
DANA VETTER: Oh, Happy
New Year, right?
BRAD PAISLEY: Yeah.
That's me.
DANA VETTER: So funny.
So we don't have
much more time.
I think we'll take one question
from the audience.
AUDIENCE: OK, I'll make
it good then.
One comment and one question.
Number one, I love your shirt,
because I think you have all
the Google colors.
BRAD PAISLEY: Yeah,
no kidding.
DANA VETTER: Oh, thanks
for doing that.
AUDIENCE: You did it on
purpose, I'm sure.
BRAD PAISLEY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Number two, here to
hear Google really big on
work-life balance.
And you sound so busy, with
writing songs, singing songs,
all of your tours.
So can you give us a little
advice on how you do it?
BRAD PAISLEY: I sleep
very little.
And that's not good advice.
But, I think that it seems
busier than it really is when
you are in the public eye.
So I have people say, you must
never see your family.
But I saw them yesterday,
before I flew out.
And I'll see 'em again before
the weekend's over.
And then, I'm home
for four days.
And I'll cram.
And it's sort of like if I'm
home four days out of seven on
any given week, I make sure
those four days are a heavy
majority for my kids and wife.
And in that sense, I spend more
time, maybe, with my kids
than somebody who has a 9:00 to
5:00 day job, that doesn't
get home til 6:00 or so.
And their kids probably
go to bed at 8:00.
So they have, maybe, two hours
at the end of the day, where
they got to catch up.
And in my case, you know, we
have days together that are
all-day events.
And then, it's sort of like when
the family goes to bed,
I'll write or I'll work.
And there's chunks of time
where I work really hard
making an album for six months,
where your mind is
sort of hazy and you're out
there thinking about it.
And then, there's other times
when I'm doing less.
And it is a challenge.
And wives are good at reminding
you your balance is
off a little bit
in a good way.
And your kids are good at
reminding you of that, too.
You know, in the middle of the
writing, I'll be typing a lot
of things in a phone or a tablet
or something, and my
kids will say, you never
look up from that.
And then, that's a sign.
It's like, OK, wait a minute.
I need to put that down.
Life is a balance, though.
And you are your balance.
You are that person,
you know, I think.
You can't say, well, no,
I'm really their dad.
I just never see them.
Then, you're not.
You know, you have to
find that, I think.
DANA VETTER: So what's
next for you?
Are you the type of songwriter
where you have a lot kind of
going on, you're writing on the
road, and you have a lot
of material, like, for
your next album?
Or are you focused right now
on the tour now, the "Beat
This Summer Tour" and
"Wheelhouse," and then you'll
take a break?
What's kind of next for you?
BRAD PAISLEY: I'm not writing
songs much right now.
Because I think that you
have to recharge.
I heard a great songwriter
once say you need input.
You know, just like any
computer, it needs input to
have any sort of output.
And you have to live a little
bit and observe especially,
read, which I just
learned to do.
[LAUGHTER]
BRAD PAISLEY: It's a
whole new world.
I mean, I'm learning right along
with my six-year-old.
No, really, it's about that.
And so this is more of
a absorption time--
DANA VETTER: OK.
BRAD PAISLEY: --for me.
But we have some really cool
things we're about to do.
I can't really announce
it yet.
But we're working on a really
large way of illustrating this
new single in a way that is
bigger than a music video and
is more of a strong sort
of case for what the
point of the song is.
And, you know, in that sense,
that's the fun part about
being in music, is I think
music now can be this
multifingered thing, where you
have all of these various
channels that you get to do
if you are successful.
People know your name.
They're interested in what
you're doing for some reason.
And anything you can do to help
the point of something
you believe in is fun--
DANA VETTER: Um, hm.
BRAD PAISLEY: --you know,
in that sense.
DANA VETTER: So when should we
look out for this new thing?
BRAD PAISLEY: I think
in a week or two--
DANA VETTER: Oh, soon!
BRAD PAISLEY: --we'll start
talking about it, yeah--
DANA VETTER: Great.
BRAD PAISLEY: --if
all goes well.
DANA VETTER: OK.
BRAD PAISLEY: We're sort of in
talks to do something cool.
And if you don't hear about
it, then it didn't happen.
DANA VETTER: And something
fell through.
BRAD PAISLEY: Right.
DANA VETTER: Well, I think
we're about out of time.
We're going to go give you a
bit of a Google tour now.
But thank you so much
for joining us.
[APPLAUSE]
BRAD PAISLEY: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
BRAD PAISLEY: Thanks for
doing what you do.
DANA VETTER: Thanks for
taking the time.
[APPLAUSE]
BRAD PAISLEY: I never knew it
took so many people to put,
like, white and blue search
results up on a screen.
It's, like, crazy.
AUDIENCE: Like Texas.
DANA VETTER: There's thousands
more of us, too.
BRAD PAISLEY: Yeah, I bet.
AUDIENCE: Like she just said.
BRAD PAISLEY: Thank you.
DANA VETTER: Thank you.